ми зараз галичині води на базар
Вдалого 8 адже ти по видного так
звіду Юрія Луценка ставши генпрокурором
такого був казково should come а у
значенні голови у експерта здається
бачили шукаю правда з метою розпізнають
стиль лише його за переднього президента
всі на році їм вони годинник януковича cool і
буду до молодості між фракцією то їм
самим зміцнює купалася депутати щоб
голосував через них і потім дуже швидко
без додавши і вмовляннями ви добувалося
голосуванням захворювала міжнародну
спи ноту сам президент ніби схожим на
свого тата джерелами хоче на
подання нового генпрокурора зусилля
канатика та новий учень та пу-за лижним
не будемо ви нікому і нічим не забув я за
вони президентові ще хоче по степу що ти
вони уряду вони парламенту, а не буде їй
політичній силі з повністю розв'язані
руки у team за словами експертів обожнювання
5 м'яти піци б підсилення владою президент
сам загнав себе у cut поставили на
ключові зайти своїх людей не потрібен
викладені зробить і вид паве дальність за
провал реформ жінка політичними
партнерами міжнародної spilota донори
тих хто петру і муть україну в мфц буду
типу скарбу ти в туві дальності за
реформи особисту на порошенко
ірану че визнана так само зарубати
вибір ти пораниш яценюк би дорівнює себе
багата критики зайнявши до чого вінду в
шаленою популярним лише президент
порошенка нинішніх проше на клабі травня
покличте так молодий і вигляд побачили на
очі все босом і всі мають рацію на спади на
його при значенні на ключові по саду
своїх людей проїжджати експерти
зроблю йдуть а ще рішення про хвали в
цю муть а за зачиненими дверима
ми з публічних а часом і піди куди стану
7 прийомним сюрпризом для населення